I am live I think in my life I am live
on my mobile don't know whether it makes
a difference all right cool not sure if
I can rotate this okay I can rotate this
never mind sorry guys if you want a
clearer view probably go on to Facebook
okay I don't know what's going on with
YouTube today and I can't seems to I
can't seem to figure it out I'm gonna
just bear with me okay I'm gonna go live
on Facebook as well yeah let me just go
live on Facebook as well technology
everything is not working today you know
what I actually just finished my workout
so I did 45 minutes of strength training
just now yeah it was really good and I
just had my dinner as well it was late I
started my workout at about I mean it's
not too late about seven to eight and
then rush through my dinner just so that
I can chat with all of you
yay let's chat can you see me can you
hear me
Kenya you lost 94 pounds
thanks to my videos I would love to see
your before and after picture cool one
second
let me go live on Facebook as well
yay hi Ankita um so right always
everything so big today
so hang on yeah today somehow
everything's just slow high cards are
for more ago right so can i landscape my
phone I want to I wish to I don't know
what I can do it how do I do this
no that's no I'm just showing you my
that's all
orientation is locked rooted device back
sorry guys you just gotta have to bear
with me today okay okay um one second
one second what if I try to go live on
my
I pad
no no nevermind okay right I'm just
going to give you one more try I'm going
to try to go live on Facebook if it
doesn't work forget about it I'm just
going to start chatting with all of you
okay just give me one second okay one
second okay guys I'm so sorry about this
I am so sorry about this I'm not sure
what's wrong don't know what this in my
internet connection or is it just me not
knowing how to fix things you should
just be simple click and play
right
let's chat
your life
okay I believe I'm like right now cool
how do I make this yeah cool did you
know what okay right so you know I
forgot about it I'm just gonna start
chatting with you guys right I'm just
going to side chatting hey I don't know
why my facebook is not working I'll
probably try it again later on um yeah
so let's just have a casual chat
I actually just like I say just like I
just finished my workout and did
strength training so if you have any
questions right now I would love to hear
from you
and yeah I'll try my best to answer all
I can okay um write the comments are
going really fast Priya you said you
asked about giving tips for getting
slimmer arms can I just say that arms
are one of the most common areas that we
women struggle with so I just uploaded a
video yesterday it's a strength training
upper body video that combines
kickboxing as well and I personally find
that whenever you do kickboxing moves
because it requires a lot of punches and
hooks and things like that it really
helps with your arms so I would
definitely recommend you trying out the
video okay try it out do it at least two
to three times weekly on alternate days
and you would definitely see results
Deborah Priya how do I control my food
cravings hmm
that's a million-dollar question isn't
it one thing that I find which has been
really helpful to me because I would say
that for the past week work has been
quite stressful and things like that so
I do sometimes fall into mindless
snacking but one thing that I find
really helped me out to control my food
cravings and to keep me full is actually
adding chia seeds into your water so in
fact I've been drinking that on a daily
basis and I find that it is really
feeling for those of you who might not
know I actually fasted the entire day
yesterday so I fasted for 14 hours which
means no food and drinks so I woke up at
5 8 5 a.m. and I had to force myself to
eat because I knew that I can't eat
until 7:30 p.m. at night so what I ate
was I had a bowl of overnight oats
together with two glasses of chia seeds
and that combination really works so I I
it's not that I did not feel hungry
throughout the day but I did not feel
the crazy urge that I need to eat so I
lasted throughout the whole day with no
food no water and when I started eating
at 7:30 I did not go crazy so I was
pretty much in control of my food intake
so personally I find that oats really
help chia seeds really help as well if
you do struggle with food cravings just
try to add one this has no chances but
just try to add one tablespoon of chia
seeds into your water and drink that
throughout the day ok it really helps
right
Ayesha I'm really happy to hear that
you lost a lot of weight through my
videos guys don't be rude please we're
not here to be rude to each other ok
Nisha you want to lose weight by you do
not know where to start I actually
created a video two years ago on 7 steps
to start losing weight permanently if
you can't go to my youtube channel and
search for that video it's a long video
it's 20 minutes but it really took the
time to explain as much details as I can
to kick start you on a weight-loss
journey so take the time and watch the
video 3 ok hey Angelica from the
Philippines hair Hurley I'm doing detox
but I don't know what I'm doing what do
you mean by that
hi morning it's actually I mean it's
actually 9:15 here one second let me
just try this once more ok
Google I I'm just feeling bad for those
on Facebook they're not actually seeing
this life right hopefully it works now
it's so early in America hi Giselle good
morning thanks for waking up that early
Monica you have a really valid question
how to eat healthy while living with
unhealthy parents that that won't change
okay to answer that I don't believe in
changing people I don't believe that you
can change someone overnight so based on
my personal experience I would say that
I am rather healthy whereas my brother
is not you know he's not into healthy
living and things like that so it's
always a struggle whenever I'm with him
because he would want to eat you know
the kind of like deep fried huge portion
food whereas that's not what I want so I
don't believe that you can change
someone but I believe what you can do is
to be aware of a food intake um eat the
way that you want to eat eat healthily
and slowly you will influence those
around you okay so there is there is no
way that you can change your parents but
you can influence them to start eating
like you you can even start cooking for
them if you can cook make lunch for them
prog dinner for them make breakfast for
them and don't tell them that it's
healthy sometimes there's this thing
about the mindset of when people think
that it's healthy they just think that
it's not good it's not delicious and
it's just you you know why don't want to
eat healthy so the trick that I've learn
is don't tell them is healthy just cook
for them and you know just tell that
it's really delicious
it's it tastes just as good as your
normal pasta for instance and they you
might be surprised that they will enjoy
more when they don't know that a food is
healthy as such okay so that's one tip
that I found out to be really useful
right let me just go into this
brand you asked about your six week
postpartum I would definitely recommend
you watching the post pregnancy workout
video that I just did with Nika I
believe two weeks ago so that video
would really help you to kickstart your
weight loss journey after pregnancy
because there are certain moves that you
should not be doing after pregnancy so
do watch the video because Nika release
um you know teacher in detail what you
can do and what you can't do okay so
watch the video before you even try to
start losing weight after pregnancy hi
amorta beast I'm doing well what cut
right wait right okay sorry one second
just reading Nichole do I use apple
cider vinegar very much to simply answer
your question not really because
personally I am NOT a big fan of apple
cider vinegar so I do still struggle to
like the taste so to be honest I don't
really use apple cider vinegar I add a
little bit into my water just to gain
the benefits but you know to also dilute
the taste hoping hopefully the future I
like it better right uh so in term in
term it and fasting it is kind of a big
thing right now where you don't have
breakfast and then you have a bigger
lunch and a bigger dinner what do I
think of that personally I feel that the
diet or the food intake or you know the
time that you eat your food really
depends on your personal lifestyle so if
you're someone that can go without food
in the morning because say your
lifestyle your work life or your study
life doesn't require you to be
physically active then by all means you
can do intermittent fasting because at
the end of the day it is not about what
time you eat your meal and things like
that it is really about the total food
intake for the entire day so if you were
to spread up your food if you were to
spread out your food intake say to
in calories into six meals or you would
to spread it out into three meals it
still equals the same thing okay so it
really depends on your personal
lifestyle some people yes they can have
the time to eat six smaller meals but
for a lot of us it is not realistic to
prep six smaller meals so we tend to eat
three larger meals which is what I tend
to do as well I don't really eat five to
six small meals I eat I would say for
larger meals and and if you are some of
their works late at night then by all
means you can eat late and I okay it
doesn't mean that when you eat late at
night you again wait no it really comes
down to your total calorie intake so
yeah right one second
hi share him you have lost six kilos in
two months that is actually a really
good weight loss pace the weight loss
ratio is usually between 0.5 to 1 kilos
a week so 1 kilo a week so you are doing
a good job and you're on track ok
because the goal is to be able to
sustain your weight loss after you've
reached your ideal weight I just saw a
Japanese character like words I can't
read Japanese
okay
one second yeah guys I'm just gonna
leave a comment quickly here I'm just
telling the guys on Facebook that I
can't go live and ask for them to come
on YouTube hi Chris you love her Network
but is it only on YouTube or is it a
blog or another channel or what thank
you so much thank you so much for loving
her network at the moment it is only on
YouTube because essentially it is part
of my channel which I want to slowly try
and see it into her network and I'm
really glad that you enjoy the content
like I said last week during my live
chat the whole goal is to be able to
offer you guys more value so wellness
covers not just fitness and food but it
is also your state of mind hence I
wanted to bring on what other critters
other female that are experts in their
own rights to come on board and offer
you a lot more besides what I've been
sharing with you you know exercises like
yoga for moms I have videos on cooking
with kids so the whole goal is to be
able to offer video content but we do
also have our own website and also
Facebook and Instagram page so yep just
start it off
started in May and it is growing and you
know guys thanks so much very support hi
Sam from England
gosh I miss England so much want to go
back there for holiday soon Sarah what
do you do when you reach a plateau when
you reach a plateau what I would say is
stop everything you're doing and change
you know stop everything you're doing
basically in fact I am going to create a
video on that I have a video on that as
well so if you're someone that has been
exercising regularly with a set kind of
routine mix that up because your body is
so used to that routine it is it's not
going to react to that written anymore
so for instance if you have been going
to the gym or if if you
running try something different try
hiking try kickboxing try swimming mix
up your routine introduce new elements
to your workout then your body will
start burning again if you have been
restricting your diet too long you can
also hit a plateau so what I would
recommend is you know don't follow your
eating habits just eat whatever you want
for a good one or two days then you will
kick start your metabolism again a lot
of based on my personal experience some
of my clients in the past when they are
stuck to a certain routine they can't
seems to progress anymore when they go
on a holidays when they rest and do
absolutely nothing that's where they
start losing weight again okay so it's
about breaking a routine and introducing
new elements or taking rest sleeping
more eating different kinds of food
mixing up your meals confuse your body
so that your body will start burning
again right hey little kit from Germany
can a girl exercise during her period
yes absolutely you can totally exercise
during your period if you're absolutely
fine there's no reason why you should
stop working out if you do experience
cramp bloating uncomf you know stomach
discomfort then do some gentle yoga
exercises that some gentle stretches to
release the bloating okay and on the
second day if you're absolutely fine
then by all means get back into your
routine
right colon should I start diet and
exercise at the same time for weight
loss or should I start with weight loss
diet first - well you should start with
both really I mean at the end of the day
you are gaining both and it really
depends on how heavy you are if you're
someone that is extremely extremely
extremely overweight then some then most
likely you will have to start by cutting
down on your food portion because you
might not be able to do really active
stuff to start working out so you can
start with really gentle exercises such
as walking but if you're slightly
overweight you're not extremely obese
when I say extremely obese I mean
someone that weighs more than 120 150
kilos ok some of these extremely obese
but if you don't fall under the category
then by all means stop introducing both
elements because the quicker you
understand about healthy living the
quicker the sooner you understand about
eating right the sooner you learn how to
do certain exercises the better you will
be at it and the quicker you will pick
it up and the quicker your results will
be as well so definitely start on both
okay unless you have a doctor's
recommendation saying that you can't do
this workout with that workout
okay one second
you're trying to go live on Facebook huh
did I ever cut like did you ever
consider to do vlogs Roxanna yes and I
don't know I'm just I don't know I just
do you know what I struggled to like put
a camera in front of me all the time and
just vlog about my life I'm not that
kind of person
I do appreciate my own privacy and my
own quiet time as well so to be honest I
I don't know I don't fancy the idea of
just vlogging my entire life if that
makes sense you know like let's say if
I'm spending time with my mom or if I
was spending time with my friends I
don't just want to have that camera
constantly in their face
so I might vlog when I travel and things
like that but not just like on a daily
basis yeah cuz because I'm online so
often it is nice to just have my own
quiet time as well away from the camera
digital detox so I hope that makes sense
Chaz Chaz shares I'm thirteen can I lift
weights of course you can lift weights
there's nothing stopping you from
lifting weights okay but if you're 13
it's important to understand that your
body is to developing your body is to
growing and you will constantly you will
still grow until at least 18 or 20 years
old so at that age don't be so rigid in
you know don't be so rich in your
workout routine what is more important
is to just go with your friends have fun
do activities that you enjoy it doesn't
have to involve weightlifting just do
something that you enjoy at the end of
the day your body is you developing and
growing
oh hey guys see me Facebook guys
okay right
and finally live on Facebook sorry guys
on YouTube I'm just gonna quickly type
up Facebook okay okay cool let's
continue so um
guys on Facebook and also live on
YouTube right now I had some issues just
hung with technology so heads I can't go
live Christine do you recommend
exercising the following day if you're
super soft from the previous day's work
out to answer your question yes and no
if you're extremely sore and you can't
even sit on the chair you can't even sit
on the toilet bowl then yes you should
be moving okay because what is happening
to your body is that there are a lot of
lactic exit being buildup in your
muscles so if you just sit and do
nothing
guess what the soreness will still stay
anyway still remain there so what you
should be doing is go for a gentle walk
or stretch out okay so yes you should
still be moving but you shouldn't
constantly be doing intense workout
every single day and take no rest at all
because what a lot of us tend to forget
is that your muscles will grow when you
rest
so resting is equally just as important
as working out hence if you don't have
time if you were to do like a total body
workout for example I I would recommend
doing your workout every alternate days
so Monday Wednesday Friday therefore
you're allowing your body to rest on
Tuesday and Thursday resting is equally
just as important as exercising okay
don't go crazy don't go all out and then
see no results because you're just
straining your body or just overworked
your body right I'm gonna answer a
question a few questions from Facebook
as well
hi guys on Facebook again sorry sorry
for being half an hour late because yeah
do you know what to work just now
right I want to lose I want to get a
flat tummy boot without exercising huh
well to simply answer you flat belly
when it comes to exercising a flat belly
there isn't much so to get a flat value
without exercising it is very possible
if you were to watch your food intake
your stress level your sleep level your
hormone levels okay that is what those
other things that contribute more to
belly fat belly fat is due to
inflammation in your tummy belly fat is
due to inflammation in your tummy okay
so whenever you feel bloated or you're
constipated
that's because of your tummy being
implemented so oh god my facebook life
just went off again I'm just slightly
distracted right now so the more the
better you are the better your digestive
system is the better your tummy will
look as such so if you have a healthy
digestion that's when you feel good and
you feel that your belly is flat as well
so belly fat if you're really concerned
about it watch over your lifestyle okay
when I talk about lifestyle it's not
just your exercise or you know the food
you eat but it really comes down to your
stress level if you were to over workout
your body is also constantly at a high
stress level therefore you will also not
see results so it is very important to
Altan your workout between high
intensity and also low intensity workout
grace to answer grace you you asked me
what is my height and weight I'm I'm one
five nine centimeters to be exact so I'm
not even 160 centimeters and my weight
right now buck shoe eights between 49 to
51 kilos so guys your weight fluctuates
up to five pounds a day okay so my
weight fluctuates between 49 to 51 kilos
and I don't kill my macros I know that's
just not something I do it's just too
much you know I really have a lot of
things going on in my life and for me
it's all about if for me it's all about
80% eating healthy and 20% enjoy what I
want if I feel good that's what matters
most to me so I'm not that kind of
person that goes crazy or really desire
a six-pack you know like six packs
that's not me for me Fitness is my
lifestyle and I want to sustain that for
life and I want it to not disturb my
work life as well so because you know
let's be realistic I can't be spending
two three hours in the gym and just
focusing on how my body looks so Fitness
is beyond my you know my physical
appearance to me that is how I view
fitness right now when I first started
yes it's all about looking good you know
it's about having a toned body but right
now it is part of me and I wanted to add
on to my life rather than being the main
focus being the only priority in my life
because if I do that everything else
will suffer my work will suffer my
relationship with my family will suffer
and things like that
hey guys on Facebook
Kayle Yanni hye-kyo Yanni can you see me
on Facebook I'm not sure what's going on
today something is not right is it
possible rosh roshni is it possible to
lose six kilos in three months yes it is
very possible in fact that is a good
weight loss ratio so it is very possible
to lose six kilos in three months very
very possible tips to be motivated ban
ban ban lease whirl right motivation
doesn't just you don't wake up feeling
motivated every day I don't wake up
feeling motivated motivated every day
whether it's regards to fitness or you
know sometimes even to film videos I
don't I don't always feel motivated
I think motivation it has to be beyond
motivation so what I believe in is to
build discipline so that's something
that I think is more important than
motivation because discipline is about
doing things even we don't feel like
doing it and the more you do things that
you know will do good for you even we
don't feel like doing it you're building
yourself you're building a routine for
yourself that and you're also building a
stronger mindset so let's say if you
don't feel like working out today the
longer it takes you to think about not
working out you know what get up and do
something I don't care if it's only ten
minutes just get up and do it every time
you do something that you don't feel
like doing it you're building discipline
and so eventually your mind will be
stronger than your feelings is like you
know it's not it's not about how I feel
all the time I don't believe I don't
believe in living life according to how
you feel all the time because if you
just go according to how we feel all the
time then we'll get nothing done will
not achieve anything so next time if I
see you guys saying that oh I'm not
motivated well you know what you just
got to get up and do it it's all about
doing it it's all about doing things
until eventually your mind is stronger
than you're feeling
your negative feelings
right
okay I'm going to answer a few questions
on Facebook it's a bell you have lost 50
kilos by following my workouts and
eating healthy can you share your
before-and-after picture because I would
love to see that okay oh gosh
I'm not ignoring you Selena haha I'm not
ignoring you as your question I'm gonna
try my best to answer all of it
the Rhea your 70 kilos we started my
workout but you want to give up easily
rehab my best advice for you right now
is set yourself a realistic goal okay
when the the starting part whether it's
your weight loss journey whatever you do
in life the starting part is always the
hardest so in order not to fail I
believe in setting yourself a realistic
goal so instead of saying I'm gonna hit
the gym five to six times a week
set yourself a realistic go if you know
you can only do it three times a week
then say okay I'm gonna do it three
times a week and instead of pushing
yourself to do a one hour workout start
with half an hour workout because then
by being able to complete what you set
yourself up for it will motivate you it
will encourage you to push further so
don't be overly ambitious when you set
yourself goals set yourself a realistic
goal every time you achieve it reward
yourself by doing something you enjoy
that doesn't mean that you should reward
yourself with food okay we're not
animals you know we're not dogs we
shouldn't constantly be rewarding
ourselves with food I don't believe in
that so yeah first step set yourself a
realistic goal and once you achieve that
it would push you to go further okay and
don't be demotivated if you miss one day
of work out or if you you know just eat
unhealthily one day because habits take
time to develop and it takes time it
takes time to change what we are so used
to so don't be the motivator pick
yourself back up start again the next
day I'm going to answer a question on
Facebook when did I start working out so
I started working out if you watched my
life stream last week I as a teenager I
was a very enough leg lazy girl I only
started working out when I was 18 years
old so wow it's almost 10 years now
since I started so I started working out
when I was 18 years old when I was in
college went to the gym did not know
what I was doing
joined classes and then slowly I picked
up on you know understanding how
exercise
how my body works and then eventually
took up personal training courses and
yeah so it doesn't say a question I
started when I was 18 really late did
not know nothing about healthy eating
until probably when I lived on my own in
the UK and like 20 or 21 years old hey
guys
I'm gonna answer another question on
Facebook I think this is a really good
question um
so John Juhan do I plan my meals yes I
can I do plan my meals so for instance
just simply put it breakfast lunch
dinner I know that I can plan my
breakfast and dinner well lunch because
I'm at work and most of the time I have
lunch meetings so breakfast I always
have my breakfast at home I yeah I've
always have my breakfast at home whether
it's overnight oats oatmeal bread and
toes I mean toast and egg I always make
sure that I have my breakfast at home
and then I'll go to work
film videos edit videos for lunch
if there's nothing on for the day then I
like to take pack lunch to work as well
but if there's like a lunch meeting then
obviously I would go up for my meeting I
have lunch then as for dinner if s for
dinner I like to cook myself and cook at
home but if there are plans with friends
then I would go out and have you know
dinner with my friends so I'm not a very
restricted person I'm not the kind of
person where I don't want to be you know
Fitness is my lifestyle I don't want to
be socially awkward so I don't want to
be that kind of person where when you go
with your friends it's like oh you know
what everybody's staring at you you
can't eat this you don't want to eat
that you feel guilty eating this your
friends are staring at you and you know
it's just it's just not a very healthy
place to be in and I don't I don't want
to you know be that I don't want food to
take over my life or eating help you to
take over my life so I would say that we
days I can plan my nail as as you know
as often as possible weekend's I try to
just take it easy questions hi Katherine
my very first fitness trainer by YouTube
hi Katherine on Facebook right let's go
back to YouTube eight days do you go
crazy with cheat days you mean cheat
days do you go crazy with them or do you
just eat one bad item and how does it
affect your body please um no I don't go
crazy on Tuesdays no I definitely
we don't go crazy on chi days and I
think that if you're someone that goes
crazy on chi days I don't think it's
healthy I think you undo all your effort
over the week you know let's say if you
you're very good you're very disciplined
over the weekdays and you just go crazy
over the weekends and eat whatever you
want I think pretty much you're undoing
all the effort that you know you've been
working so hard for over the weekdays so
what I practice is moderation always
moderation so instead of going crazy
like instead of stuffing you know like
restricting myself not to have that
chocolate cake or not to have that ice
cream over the weekdays and then over
the weekends it as much ice cream as I
want I would rather have you know like a
little bit of say one or two pieces of
chocolate every single day or have like
a small piece of cake or you know share
with my friends I would rather do that
so that I don't I don't restrict myself
at the same time I don't have these
crazy cravings so to answer yourself no
I don't go crazy days definitely not no
hi Catherine how much water do I drink a
day
I'm 2.5 to 3 liters yes
obviously the her thunk that is where I
struggle to hit that goal okay but right
now cheers guys lemon cucumber and
cinnamon sip it all day long bring this
to you or bring this to work okay bring
this to school whenever wherever hmm ah
so good
cow please don't please guys tell her
reply me right okay I'm another question
hi Joanna green tea i brewed coffee
definitely green tea anytime green tea
love my green tea I have it every day
and in fact tomorrow
I'm going to film five food that I eat
every day and why you guys should also
be eating it and green tea is one of
them mmm right how do I pay my exercise
on the busy schedule how do you manage
strength cardio and apps in a week
Simran if you have a busy schedule don't
split your workouts okay don't try to
don't attempt doing say cardio on Monday
Wednesday Friday and a strength training
on Tuesday Thursday if you have a busy
schedule is better to pack all three
workouts say strength cardio and apps
which is what my workout videos are
essentially in two three or four days a
week so then you're not having the
stress to think that oh my god I have to
work out every single day so if you only
can work out three times a week
start with warm-up get into your
strength training say twenty thirty
minutes of strength training then any
workout with ten to fifteen minutes of
cardio and also core so pack your
workout into yours interest credit that
fits you okay if it's morning great if
it's evening equally just as great be
mentally stronger than what you
physically feel that is so true
hence that is why I decided to fast
yesterday because I just wanted to know
that I'm in control of what I eat
because I'd be eating rather bad for the
past three days so I you know what I
just thought talked to myself you know
what faster Anna be mentally stronger
than how you physically feel
right let me answer
right let me answer a question on
YouTube exercise for women above 50
years old gotcha
gonna work on that okay I'm gonna work
on that I'm seriously I'm gonna work on
that I need to block people thanks ash
on C for sharing your feedback Green C
is the business I stopped drinking
coffee because it was messing with my
stomach and made me feel tired
afterwards actually it is so true wait
how do I get this up okay
drinking tea still gives me that small
bus of caffeine and delicious juice the
green tea
okay right mm-hmm how do I do with
negative comments good question to be
honest I've learned to not take that
personally it's because the energy you
choose to fit into your life the energy
you choose to attract into your life
will affect the way you live your life
and you know it will affect you as a
person so for me there will always be
haters no matter what you do no matter
where you are there will always be
people who do not agree with what you do
or perhaps they're just jealous of you
and yeah I mean why feed on to the
energy why spend your time even reading
or even commenting on those kind of
comments so I personally choose not to
just I personally choose not to reply
them unless it's a valid comment and
because do you know what I have I'm
better off spending my time talking to
all of you that's what I choose to do
Kantar you want to lose 20 kilos in
three months again it's very important
to set a realistic goal okay so if you
can go and watch my seven steps to
permanent weight loss video and it will
explain everything you need to know in
regards to weight loss the realistic
goal you should be setting yourself
because remember you did not put on
twenty kilos in three months it took you
several months or even years to put on
twenty kilos so don't expect to lose
twenty kilos in three months we always
want quick results what about you know
working hard for something you want what
about being disciplined and have the you
know mentality to really go all out and
achieve what you want a few prop when
you achieve it so I don't believe in
quick results
the sooner you stop looking for quick
results the sooner you stop looking for
quick fix that's when you will start
achieving real sustainable results which
you will be able to maintain for life
okay yes you might be able to lose say
20 kilos in 3 months I can guarantee you
you will not be able to maintain it I
can guarantee you that and I can also
assure you you might put on even more
than 20 kilos up to three months so guys
please set yourself a realistic goal
start looking for a quick weight loss
solution that's a work long-term
okay okay right and question from
Facebook
cien cien hi Jonah what is your fitness
goal are you aiming to gain muscles on
maintain your weight so currently my
fitness goal is pretty much to maintain
my weight I wouldn't mind getting a
little bit of muscle to tone up and yeah
I mean I don't really have a specific
fitness goal my fitness goal as such is
to is to just be able to stay healthy
because by staying healthy I'm able to
continue to do what I do which is pretty
much continue to film videos continue to
create fitness content health-related
content and right now I am I I mix my
workouts up a lot to be honest I'm
trying different things just to keep it
interesting all the time so that I don't
feel bored so yeah I'm just mixing my
workouts up I'm really open to try new
things my chamber is so vague okay let's
answer a question from YouTube
ah Sh sorry Akshaya can we have rising
breakfast and serious in lunch and
fruits and vegetables in night can
anyone and can anyone and this um well
pretty much you can eat any time of you
can't eat anything any time of the day
or you know mix it over depends on how
you like it but lunch I maybe not like I
mean rice rice has the effect of making
you [ __ ] and it will it also helps with
sleep okay so if you have the time go
and watch my why I eat white rice video
rice actually has the coming end you
know it's sleeping effect that is why
for those of you who tend to eat lunch
I'm in touch it rice for lunch or
breakfast if you over eat it you will
find yourself feeling very sleepy after
lunch yes for sure it is a yes
okay so personally yes you can have rice
if you want for breakfast but personally
I would not do that because for
breakfast you want to start off with a
meal that would give you sustainable
energy throughout the day not something
that would just make you you know feel
sluggish
so in fact I personally eat rice during
dinner okay I know that some people say
that you don't should have been you
shouldn't be having carbs during
dinnertime but you know what that's not
how your body works in fact I find that
having rise during dinner helps me to
wind down and sleep better and I don't
want to feel sluggish midday or even in
the morning so have rice for dinner and
it's all about the portion green tea
recommendation like I say before I enjoy
my Japanese green tea brand so I don't
really have a specific brand but the
type of green tea I like again my cha
okay again my choice basically roasted
green tea with roasted rice and I really
like that get my cha it's really
delicious right
Johanne ho how to work around muscle
imbalance to work around muscle
imbalance it's always good to work on
so-so to work on muscle imbalance it's
always good to work on your left arms or
your left legs separate from your right
legs so instead of for instance instead
of using barbells and lift and do bicep
curls chances are you will you know your
compensate your right hand will be
helping your left hand so use dumbbells
instead where you know that your left
hand your right hand can be helping your
left hand so use weights which are used
dumbbells you know I find that it works
for most imbalance and things like that
when you have to focus solely on one
muscle at a time
that helps can you give me a 5 right
gosh he it's almost 10 Wow high five
none I'm a big fan of yours I've been
following your meal plan and getting
results oh thank you so much I really
hope that all of you enjoy the meal plan
I'm trying to create at least one meal
plan every month so for last month I
creates a a Ramadan meal plan for next
month I'm hoping to create a soup
cleansing meal plan okay I love soup I
find that having adding stew into your
diet helps you to eat lesser it helps
you to feel fuller quicker and so I
wanted to introduce I want I want to
start introducing soup to you guys and
also hopefully you know your start
adding soup into your diet that
chocolate is healthy tanea but that
doesn't mean you should you should allow
yourself to eat as much as you want it's
also about portion control hey hey hey
okay
right
um I'm going to answer a question from
Facebook okay
guys on Facebook
who would you charge up sorry just
really a comment there hoji chair is
delicious as well try it it's delicious
can I talk about bulking up um it would
take me forever to talk about walking
out right now but I would definitely
create a video on that and I'm also
looking to work with another creator to
create a video on that so yeah
definitely in the progress hi um I'll
charm from Greece I'm from Malaysia
Kuala Lumpur right now
kill kill see can I drink green tea
daily as a substitute for drinking just
plain water to answer your question I
would I would not take I would not use
green tea to replace water because green
tea does have diuretics effects so which
means that it will also dehydrate your
body slightly so I will not compensate
water I will not come passing water for
green tea half both if you really want
to okay have both and yeah just don't
just drink green tea I don't drink water
if you want to make your water
interesting you can do this infused
water okay
right do you know what I've been
answering a lot of questions right now
so maybe I should ask all of you a
question what kind of content do you
enjoy from my videos and what do you
want to watch more off is it like
workout videos recipe video fitness tips
and have you also been watching my newer
content from her Network so what do you
enjoy from her Network obviously because
it's a new network that I just started
and I'm still experimenting with content
and yeah I'm really open to feedbacks I
want to know what you enjoy and how I
can improve on it and yeah basically to
create content that you would gain from
it
workout videos without any tools cool
hi Julie
recipes I like your weight loss video I
enjoy all your videos I love the
educational videos on fitness hi
Christina
thanks I always read your comments thank
you for always constantly commenting my
videos okay I really appreciate it
I want to know more about posture when
exercising a one awanee
I created a video on beginner dumbbell
strength training please go and watch
the video it took me a lot of effort to
create that but it literally will teach
you the proper form to do all the basic
exercises okay so do watch the video
Meggy dumbbell workouts i did a video on
that it's called how to lift to loose
weight please go watch the video ok took
me so much effort to film it and I even
have like instructions with words and
all that pointing to with southern body
parts and yeah go and watch it you will
gain from it could I do some lifestyle
vlog videos okay we'll take that on
board yep got that
thank you guys for also supporting her
network okay it is not a sponsored thing
it is a network that I started a oh what
I started a month ago and this is an
idea I've been having a year ago okay so
no sponsor in fact is something that I
have to fork out to really make it
happen
stop vlogging okay maybe I should do you
really want to know about my life I just
don't know don't know whether my life is
interesting enough for you guys in their
ways oh come on don't post a buy a
part-time job workout video with no
jumping okay low impact workout
definitely Janina beginner workout yeah
I've done a lot on that as well I hope
you do follow them
also guys um so I want to do something I
want to give back to all of you as well
that's watching this right now instead
of doing like a physical giveaway what I
want to start doing every week is to
select one I don't want to call it lucky
winner but one person where I will give
my I will give half an hour of my time
to chat with you okay so I because I'm
trying my best friend out to answer all
the questions here it's pretty much
impossible to answer everything here but
what I want to do is to select one
person and offer a half an hour to one
hour of my time just to have a chat over
Skype and ask you know just just for me
to be able to help you out with your
weight loss journey so I wanted to start
doing that on a weekly basis as well
okay so if you don't get it this time
hopefully next week or something so what
I want you to do is after this live
stream comment leave your comments below
and ask me what do you want to gain from
having a one-to-one chat with me because
yeah I I really want to be able to just
you know offer my time because I believe
that time is the most valuable thing if
I can offer my time and help you guys
out that's what I'll try to do all right
so remember to leave your comment and
let me know how I can help you out by
having a one-to-one chat yay
passive oh and you like my cute Golden
Retriever I love rusty too gonna bring
him out this weekend to a pet cafe
yeah I can't wait he's just such
adorable boy oh god I miss him right now
hahahaha okay
how to do with pain after workout gear
job how to do with pain after workout
there are a lot of tips go and check out
my 7 tips to East muscle soreness video
ok that will help you to do with pin
after workout ok so do check that out
please talk about binge eating ok I have
a video on that I'm not sure whether you
watched that already but I do have a
video on binge eating I might do an
updated version on that as well alright
guys so don't forget ok I'm so sorry for
being half an hour late today gosh don't
know why I can't go live on my YouTube I
have to try it out again so please leave
your comment let me know how you can
benefit from having a one-to-one chat
with me and yeah I will be selecting one
or two of you and yeah I'm gonna do this
every Thursday but I can't do it next
Thursday because I'll be travelling to
go coast so anyone from Gold Coast do
let me know what places I should go and
visit and yeah leave a comment on
Facebook YouTube wherever it is leave
your comment ok on this live stream and
yep we'll be creating more content soon
bye guys hopefully next livestream will
not be such a nightmare bye if your
comment